so in the in the Garden of Eden there's
Adam and Eve right the primordial human
beings and there's a walled garden
that's paradise paradise means walled
garden and Eden means well watered place
and so there's this idea that the proper
habitat of human beings is in the
amalgam of social structure and now and
nature and that's exactly right because
that's what we live in right we live in
a we never live in nature and we never
live in society we live in an amalgam of
society in nature that's the human
environment so it's a walled garden
alright and so it's a productive well
watered place where we could thrive it's
safe and it's ruled over by a farther
figure in this particular in this
particular story and that's like the you
could think about that as the spirit of
civilization that's at least one way of
considering it so well there's a snake
in the garden and it's there unbeknownst
to God roughly speaking although he
knows everything so I guess he probably
knows about the snake too and he tells
Adam and Eve not to interact with it
fine and they do and the snake wakes
them up right because when they interact
with the snake they're given a fruit
that opens their eyes and makes them
aware that they're naked and vulnerable
and then dooms them to work well I'll
tell you the whole story much later in
the course but I want to give you an
overview of it now but then there's this
really strange idea that developed over
the course of the development of not
only Christianity but Judaism and and a
number of other religions that fed into
the mainstream of Christian ideas
including Zoroastrianism there's an idea
that that emerged across a very long
period of time that the snake in the
garden was the same as Satan that the
source of all evil and I've been trying
to figure out for the longest period of
time why in the world the manifestation
of what's essentially a representation
of a predator so that's this snake and
you know the snake is associated with
trees well yes the reason for that in
all likelihood is that we dwelt in trees
right and snakes like trees and they're
around trees and they can climb trees
and and the snake was a typical predator
on our our ancient relatives but and so
that's fine so you can see that that
representation makes perfect sense
there's predators that lurk in the
garden yes obviously if you interact
with them they wake you up well if they
better wake you up because if they don't
wake you up when you interact with them
then you get eaten so it's probably just
as well to wake up even though there's
painful consequences associated with
becoming conscious and that manifests
itself immediately in the in the story
of Adam and Eve but then there's this
weird Association it's it's very
undeveloped in the biblical stories that
are part and parcel of this line of
thinking it was more like a consequence
of a cloud of mythological stories that
surrounded it but the reason for that I
think is this that imagine that what
human beings were trying to puzzle out
was the nature of the predator okay so
on one level of analysis the predator is
the thing that slinks along the ground
and the threatened sea and also it's the
thing that's your mortal enemy and that
wakes you up but then that's one
conceptualization of predator and fair
enough you can identify it and you can
take precautionary measures but a better
conceptualization of predator might be
where does it come from let's say it's a
snake well there's a layer of snake
somewhere and so if we want to get rid
of the snake
we shouldn't be conceptualizing it as a
snake we should be conceptualizing it as
one manifestation of a layer of snakes
and what we should do is go down follow
the damn snake wherever it goes and find
its lair and wipe out all of the snakes
and that's that's a more abstract
representation right it's not predator
anymore it's the source of predation and
so if you want to solve the predator
problem permanently you don't kill the
snake you get rid of all the snakes okay
so fine so and people are pretty damn
good at that and that's why you have
stories of people like Saint Patrick who
chased all the snakes out of Ireland and
all sorts of saints were snake
eradication Saints and well there's a
variety of reasons for that
but then you might think okay well the
worst predator is the lair of snakes
right but then you might think well wait
a minute the worst predator isn't the
lair of snakes maybe the worst predator
is the enemies that come to attack us
and those are human enemies and so what
we do is we defend
selves against the human enemies we put
walls around our cities we fortify our
our land and we defend ourselves against
the evil that's lurking in other
people's hearts and so that's like a
higher-order snake and then we build
these walls around us and what's inside
gets larger and larger and larger and
then what happens is the snakes start
popping up inside the cities because you
know we've pushed all the we've we've
protected ourselves from all the evil
that lurks outside but we've now created
a space where that evil can manifest
itself inside so there's criminals
inside the city and there's people who
want to bring you down and there's
malevolence within the city not only
outside so then there's the the problem
of the snake that's closer to you and
then there's the ultimate problem which
is the snake that lives in your heart
right and that's each individual's
capacity for evil and then that was
conceptualized as a transcendent spirit
right so that's the spirit of Satan
who's the who's the adversary of the
hero the adversary of the hero and
that's why there's an association
between the snake in the garden and this
this great series of mythologies about
the existence of evil itself it's a
consequence of our continued capacity to
abstract we started using the predator
detection system to detect snakes and
maybe no predatory cats and maybe birds
of prey and all that but that didn't
solve the bloody problem because just
because you hid from the predatory bird
today didn't mean the bloody thing
wasn't gonna be back tomorrow and
tomorrow starts to matter as you get
smarter and then once you're on that
pathway and you're starting to think
about abstractly about the predator the
nature of what constitutes the predator
starts to become because you're trying
to solve it across all situations
simultaneously it starts to become very
much more abstract and it ends up being
something like a personality like an
eternal personality and an eternal
personality that has its effect on
everyone all the time so and it's so
it's so interesting to see those ideas
because they basically evolved people
did not understand those ideas as they
produced them right it was all put
forward in a massive mythological
context and in a rich storied context
and the
korie's were as conscious as the
information got it was never articulated
past the level of story so remarkable
absolutely remarkable